[Music]
i i don't normally do these kind of
speeches but this feels like a big
moment
i know it's not easy being banished from
mi5 to my department
but that's on you
only screw-ups get sent to slare house
and i've got to be honest
working with you has been the lowest
point and a disappointing career
right
what are you looking for
the remnants of a once promising career
house is like prison you're not supposed
to ask what you're in for
i actually want to be useful i could not
be more bored if i tried you probably
know how many people have made it back
from our house upstairs here at regions
park bringing you up the speeds like
trying to explain norway to a dog none
come check this out hostage
he's being held here
there was something
finally happening
what's it got to do with you whatever's
going on to be handled by the real
agents
[Music]
i get it we're just slow horses i've got
one lead i have to follow them
you're going to help me oh no i'm not
liking all night and our house is part
of the snow
what do you think you're playing it
i didn't mean to kill him of course you
didn't if you meant to kill him he'd
still be alive
[Music]
you put lives in danger this is off the
box
i am directing personnel yours or
anybody else's
just covering our tracks
but it's the covering of the tracks it
always gets you in the end
you really care about them don't you no
i think they're a bunch of absolute
losers
but they're my losers
[Music]
bit nervous this is my first time
not sexually i mean with a prostitute
with a lady of
ill repute
attention
[Music]
you will repay your debt to society by
working the number of hours mandated by
the court
why were you in prison it was a
misunderstanding grandpa misunderstood
that you can't force signatures on
checks
you have been tasked with restoring this
into a community center during cleanup
duty if you find a deceased animal over
10 kilos do not touch it anything under
10 kilos that is yours can we keep it no
you may not
[Music]
what's your first impressions of our
little gang everyone's a type you've got
your right wing blow hard left wing
militant celebrity chant shifty old
timer and whatever the hell he is what
type of mic the bad boy
what's that for you studious asian good
girl
you're not considering keeping this
money we found it we're entitled to it
sorry are you citing the legal precedent
finders keepers losers weepers
[Music]
you find my money and whoever took it i
want to head on a spike
we could use this money to do something
real
we're standing here in a moment where
everything about our lives could change
i mean
this is me you're over here greg this is
you
why am i the used condo because you're
there in front of spunk and that's a
compliment not pay attention
[Music]
well we're all definitely going to jail
group hug
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
the american identity begins when
benjamin franklin knit the american
colonies together
franklin is endlessly interesting
printer scientist revolutionary he is
the only founding father who evidently
had a sense of humor
his vision is broader than the american
revolution the things that he spoke of
that he wrote about had a certain amount
of power he really was an american
genius
benjamin franklin starts monday april
4th on pbs and the pbs app
i always felt a little misplaced
[Music]
but i found this thing that i loved and
i had so much more to prove
whenever i would go people would just be
mooing
the crowd was pretty rough you do it
weird he skated as if he was being
operated by a puppeteer
it reminded me that i can't even fit
into the skateboard world
but the control he had was insane
[Music]
i was obsessed and i became a machine
that was the beginning of his launch to
become tony hawk
i was just rust into adulthood
i never thought i'd be famous
but it's the worst drug
watching tony learn is more interesting
than watching him land tricks
i was truly alone
and i had to go make a change
i had not figured out how to be a
husband or father because i didn't know
how to live my own skin
tony is always competing against tony
that's all just guts
it inspires us to do something different
i'm still trying to figure this out and
i never wanted to back down from the
challenge
i'm not gonna quit
[Music]
stupid lence cap these are priciest
moments of our youth
things are finally starting to feel
normal again and it seems suspicious
[Music]
something happened in this kid at my
school
dennis went into the woods and he didn't
come out we gotta find him who's in
why are you smiling
feels good to be solving a case again
[Music]
you used to be a crime reporter in japan
why
you think the clothes are foreign the
roads are different
yeah
listen you like busting my balls huh it
is a great joy of my life
giving up and going home is not an
option you know what i mean
you know exactly what your name
is
[Music]
and let me guess
this is how you recruit a cop
[Music]
[Applause]
with information
everything you do has consequences
[Music]
there is always a costume
[Music]
jake this is sato he's not as brooding
as he seems
[Music]
what's it like to be a yakuza i could
write about that yes
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
this world
once you open the door
it is very hard to close
[Music]
that
[Music]
don't write about this
[Music]
[Applause]
hey you're keith knight i'm an ally i
still post black squares to instagram
every week actually you can stop doing
that keith is not just an artist he is
an activist the correct term is artifice
okay
i have 15 000 followers damn keeping
cake ah
you wanted to be a big name activist
right congratulations you did that
my bro is headlining a protest no man
i'm trying to hit the club introduce the
ladies to these new abs abraham lincoln
kareem abdul-jabbar
sunshine i do hate police brutality but
i have to talk about other issues
so you can't solve one thing but you're
gonna solve everything
bigger platform comes with a bigger
microscope and activists are vicious
i told you i got this share your
thoughts on hunger daylight savings time
save the tree frogs brother
look who's cracking under pressure look
i just got to figure out how to bring
people together
activism doesn't have to be art
who wants croissants
that's the whitest [ __ ] i've heard all
day
what is this thank god almighty wifi is
free at last corporations are trash
who are you y'all got to get some black
and brown folks in here to tell you that
black wi-fi matters or whatever stupid
slogan you come up with next ain't cool
it's actually our first radio
the fist put the fist down don't get so
caught up in the cause
that you forget what is going on right
in front of you
how are we supposed to understand each
other when we're all so different show
us how you wash up doing the pits nice
turn the water off and seize the day
what about your legs the water takes the
soap and it trickles down my body oh
yeah
now who are you just go full common so
you think i should go on stage say a
bunch of vague yet uplifting [ __ ] in a
weird cadence like i'm at a poetry slam
exactly
one world
one dir oneness y'all i can't believe
you went full common girl everybody look
huh i love coming
[Music]
get ready for the main event
baby you better not be back no
photographs cause i got cataracts
i see i'm not going to get the
bachelorette party i waxed for
[Music]
some of us have to use our god-given
assets to make ends meet what ends do
you have to make me maybe you live in a
cave yeah don't act like you've never
slept with some men's to pay your gay
friend why would you pay for something
that god just gave you kick the bear out
and move in i'ma take it like a bandit
[Music]
like i'm a jamaican black woman and
she's chat hank
[Applause]
please sir can i have some more you ever
see the musical oliver that's what i was
like but for some dick
[Music]
wow you better not say it or
whatever i wasn't gonna say that i was
gonna say um look over there or whatever
what up i'm three what is your
cholesterol your three years from
collecting social security what up i'm
three what up it's your friend scorpio
what if i'm three [ __ ] if you don't
stop you white drums
[Music]
sock with a pink toe and a class full of
black children it's a sock it's probably
made out of cotton too that's what they
do lord jesus hold up you know what kind
of sock i have no stuff yeah okay you
don't have any lotion on either but
because it's white
there you are
i need to tell you something
terry i can't talk right now
it's mommy's first day back to the
office this week i don't want you to go
don't go
they're not brave like you they're too
scared to do
anything that's different anything
ta-da wow uh is it for your golf
trophies it's for you
they're turning your book into a movie i
wish i felt less itchy about it
make the most of this i don't understand
why you guys aren't answering any of my
questions
you're not saying anything
there's a lot of photos missing i hate
them well
got married without even knowing what it
would be like you could return him
and what's the reason for returning your
husband where to start
[Music]
oh god
who would do this
i'm a ghost
it's annoying that you're actually kind
of attractive
you want to take revenge like a man you
gotta dress like one
or not take revenge is the other option
i met someone oh my god is he married no
do you want dessert
[Music]
i will do bedtime that's a risky move
promising bedtime
i really don't know how you ladies do it
witchcraft mainly
oh if i am a ghost why am i still
getting cramps
it meant nothing
it was just
sex
nothing's just sex
there's more
you're not telling me just to tell me
to unburden yourself
the story's about to break
sometimes i think i'm partly to blame
let things slide
making this right is all i care about
i didn't question little things when i
should have
won't your wife be wondering where you
are
she trusts me
but little things add up
look at me
we'd like to ask you a few questions
there's been an accusation
this case should never been brought as
things away from i set the accused
barrister
i think you should publicly distance
yourself from white house
why because the behaviour of entitled
toughs is something the public no longer
finds cute i know my husband
he's a good man
he's a man
i feel very confused
about me
uh everything
james whitehouse's privilege does not
extend to rape the word rape and my name
have nothing to do with each other i
have no further questions for this
witness
i didn't do
what i'm accused of if i don't get some
order in my thoughts i don't know what
i'm gonna do
all of your stories
keep changing
for whatever reason
somebody is lying
am i looking at him
i want to pray for the supper
dear god
we pray for our family
yes that you forgive us
we ask that you show us the way here
cause we're in trouble
you made this crazy world
so maybe you can give us some sort of
hint
as to what you're up to
because i don't have the first [ __ ]
clue there is a big distance between you
and us
there is a great void i'm asking you to
fill that void i'm asking you to fill
that void
i'm asking you to come down here and
explain yourself because this world of
yours isn't quite adding up man there is
a great void
so
amen
[Music]
you ever feel like you're being followed
[Music]
well you know what they say
the wicked flee when no man pursueth
[Music]
you think we're wicked
[Music]
who's here to see salt goodman
[Music]
you're the guy right
what guy's there
[Music]
[Music]
rebuilding case against jimmy
i'm just getting warmed up
[Music]
no one knows what we're doing
[Music]
except for us
[Music]
whatever happens next
it's not going to go down the way you
think it is
[Music]
[Music]
the past
you gotta bury it
[Applause]
you gotta be ready to fight
so
when the universe [ __ ] with you
let it
asking yourself what predicaments cassie
could get into in season two well here's
a sneak peek at the new season of the
flight attendant
[Music]
hi i'm cassie and i'm an alcoholic
so most of you know my story by now
but um
i'm still a flight attendant
and i've been making better choices i
moved to la
met this great guy
picked up a part-time job
i kind of feel like i'm turning into
this whole new person
it feels like you're living in a john le
curry spy novel
[Music]
what are you involved in
i know we said no more
secrets but there's a little more
[Music]
i can't have a drink
because if i have one drink
bad things happen
now what
wow
that really rattled you
really blew some stuff apart no no no no
i am not doing this again hey you know
what cheers to making better choices
baby
[Music]
[Music]
i find this advertisement on the street
says there's plenty of jobs out west the
land of opportunity
just seems wrong to give everything up i
don't think we're giving everything up
we're just going around the
journey traveling west is a dangerous
business
this isn't what they said
this isn't what they promised i have no
medicine to prescribe to heal you
[Music]
bye paul everything is gonna be just
fine i promise
get away from me you don't need to mess
up your life over something that ain't
important
it's important to me
fortune
smile and fate i haven't seen much of
late my family came to america
on the promise of fair treatment for all
i want to believe that promise
what is it you want to be billy out
there you can be anything you want to be
let's go have some fun
you see billy there's a very fine
balance between good and evil
how about you just leave this down it's
a free country
you have been arrested for murder you're
self-defense
don't yell or i'll come back for you
you don't even know how famous you are
there are wanted posters for you all
over the state i like outlaws
tell me you're looking out for someone
what's this fella's name got several
names
well he made bonnie get antrum
and billy the kid
believe me i really do not want to kill
you
make sure he gets a decent bearing
some advice
don't mess up your own life for people
who don't
it matters to me
let's go out of some fun before
mitchell
i've had some disturbing news sir
corporation watergate uh security guards
must be wide open
the next 48 hours is gonna be crucial i
don't know how to put this uh we're
wondering about your wife
y'all gonna just stand around you want
to ask me some questions
you worked for martha mitchell's husband
yeah she's completely insane loud now
she's a truth teller unreliable i love
her
i told you no more interviews it's a
ladies magazine
i will say how i feel and if that gets
me banned off air force one i will fly
commercial so you were banned from air
force one
you're good
you can just keep your mouth shut we'll
be fine
if the american people knew half of what
i do they wouldn't have much to approve
of
the loudmouth [ __ ] wife of this was
becoming too much of a liability
where is everyone okay there's no need
to get hysterical i am calling my
husband
[Music]
there is something terrible going on
[Music]
he's saying that none of it happened a
lot of women suffer from paranoid
episodes or you're nervous dear
[Music]
should the nixon administration be
afraid of you i think you know the
answer to that girl martha are there
microphones in here you rest [ __ ]
look let's just take a breath
my mama slaps me harder than that
[Music]
we've both done terrible things in our
lives
but i believe
you can be the version of yourself that
you want to be
you tell me it's gonna be okay and that
he was right people can
change my god
forgiveness has to be earned
[Music]
everybody deserves a second chance
[Music]
i'm like legit nervous
[Music]
if i was gonna look up one problem cop
was a prime example of what's gone wrong
here in baltimore where would i start
because we wanna you know we wanna run a
little hypothetical about it
he said we're on an investigation
following time drug dealer real [ __ ]
monster right
[Music]
we uh you know we get win on where he's
keeping his cash
and we actually come upon that cash
it's right there in front of us we just
you know we take it
what would you think about that
[Applause]
everything changed when they came up
with that expression the war on drugs
with the war comes police militarization
the complete gutting of the fourth
amendment
they put me in a unit made up of a bunch
of the biggest crooks in the whole
goddamn department there's all this
money to be made and i'm somehow
supposed to be playing by the book with
these [ __ ]
so these cops caught lying
and when their abusive behavior remained
on the street they did
if it is the federal honest the case
could go on for you what case
single pablo escobar is the police
in a war you need warriors
you have enemies in a war civilians get
hurt and nobody does anything in a war
you count the bodies
and then you call them victories
aren't you angry
[Music]
[Applause]
listen here bob paramount is going to
come crashing down we need hits
you've read the godfather right
godfather sure who hasn't
we've been all over town no one wants to
make this movie so i need you to produce
it
get going
[Music]
i can't believe you told me you read it
you better be fast on the plane oh yeah
that's
big the godfather is bringing us too
many problems you want me to take care
of it
gangster movies are dead this is not
just some gangster film we need someone
who understands italians
foreign
we have to put this in the picture the
scene about gangsters arguing over sauce
no
seeing about family arguing over sauce
[Music]
i got no cast
do you think the kino is actually a
possibility cut it
nope
marlon brando is interested he's a
nutcase
can one thing go right with this picture
[Music]
you wanna make a movie that's gonna make
my people look like animals and that
ain't gonna happen i respect what you're
saying and i think i have a solution to
our problem
[Music]
you're still gonna try to make this
thing i got no choice
i took a chance on you but you stabbed
me in the back i won't judge you if you
need to walk away from this i'm not
running either
[Music]
this is what it's all about
the excitement
the thrill
that's movie magic baby
[Music]
[Music]
78.56
[Music]
heavenly father
we ask that we might be instruments in
my hand
to fix what we find broken
in the name of jesus christ
[Music]
amen
[Music]
a woman and her 15 month old child were
murdered in their home
we are asking the public for their help
we aren't a community that usually locks
its doors
so for now we feel it's prudent to err
on the side of caution
the evidence points to things and to
beliefs
that i have only ever heard whisperings
about
i don't go digging in the past
and neither should you
from the first moment anyone said eyes
on her
they were hooked
an evil presence is in his family
what if this case isn't just a husband
who turned against his wife
what if tonight is just the first edge
of a bone
finally working its way out
of our own desert's floor heads up right
now
[Music]
this goes beyond just a murder
beyond everything i believe
memories are fragile
i want us to sketch out the right man we
just need enough details for someone who
knows it
it won't work no one knows him
anchored this morning city workers found
a body from a young woman called julia
[Music]
six years ago i was cut up like
her what someone did to julia they tried
it into you
if you train to be a reporter
then this is your story
after what he did
things aren't how they should be
it starts with little things
and then big things
and nobody remembers anything different
there are multiple women dead over
multiple decades
he's the one connecting them
there'll be more
i don't know how
he's been watching me
since i was a kid
he's everybody
he's nobody
he's all the time
why are you doing this how are you doing
just because something hasn't happened
doesn't mean it won't
work all connected
things change for me just like that
and then it happens again
and again
and again
you shouldn't be here
what's his name
[Music]
who's the man who visits you
[Music]
i'm just sick of having blood on my
hands wendy
it doesn't bother you
you're so desperate to be the good guy
she's lost her whole
family
because she met
us why do you choose everyone else
over your family
don't back out on me when we're almost
done don't do that to me
bobby dies
everything
that we work for
just falls apart
welcome to my [ __ ] world
wendy
i'm scared
[Music]
we're in a lot of danger
that's your choice you're just another
criminal of me now
i can go to mexico and reestablish your
control
[Music]
you really think everything you do
is to protect your family
this will be the other day
you suggested this life
we
we chose us together
you were a good
this will salesman
you